Let's review our wish list for the characteristics
of a combinational device.
In the previous lecture we worked hard to
develop a voltage-based representation for
information that could tolerate some amount
error as the information flowed through a
system of processing elements.
We specified four signaling thresholds: V_OL
and V_OH set the upper and lower bounds on
voltages used to represent 0 and 1 respectively
at the outputs of a combinational device.
V_IL and V_IH served a similar role for interpreting
the voltages at the inputs of a combinational
device.
We specified that V_OL be strictly less than
V_IL, and termed the difference between these
two low thresholds as the low noise margin,
the amount of noise that could be added to
an output signal and still have the signal
interpreted correctly at any connected inputs.
For the same reasons we specified that V_IH
be strictly less than V_OH.
We saw the implications of including noise
margins when we looked at the voltage transfer
characteristic - a plot of V_OUT vs. V_IN
- for a combinational device.
Since a combinational device must, in the
steady state, produce a valid output voltage
given a valid input voltage, we can identify
forbidden regions in the VTC, which for valid
input voltages identify regions of invalid
output voltages.
The VTC for a legal combinational device could
not have any points that fall within these
regions.
The center region, bounded by the four threshold
voltages, is narrower than it is high and
so any legal VTC has to a have region where
its gain is greater than 1 and the overall
VTC has to be non-linear.
The VTC shown here is that for a combinational
device that serves as an inverter.
If we're fortunate to be using a circuit technology
that provides high gain and has output voltages
close the ground and the power supply voltage,
we can push V_OL and V_OH outward towards
the power supply rails, and push V_IL and
V_IH inward, with the happy consequence of
increasing the noise margins - always a good
thing!
Remembering back to the beginning of Lecture
2, we'll be wanting billions of devices in
our digital systems, so each device will have
to be quite inexpensive and small.
In today's mobile world, the ability to run
our systems on battery power for long periods
of time means that we'll want to have our
systems dissipate as little power as possible.
Of course, manipulating information will necessitate
changing voltages within the system and that
will cost us some amount of power.
But if our system is idle and no internal
voltages are changing, we'd like for our system
to have zero power dissipation.
Finally, we'll want to be able to implement
systems with useful functionality and so need
to develop a catalog of the logic computations
we want to perform.
Quite remarkably, there is a circuit technology
that will make our wishes come true!
That technology is the subject of this lecture.
The star of our show is the metal-oxide-semiconductor
field-effect transistor, or MOSFET for short.
Here's a 3D drawing showing a cross-section
of a MOSFET, which is constructed from a complicated
sandwich of electrical materials as part of
an integrated circuit,
so called because the individual devices in
an integrated circuit are manufactured en-masse
during a series of manufacturing steps.
In modern technologies the dimensions of the
block shown here are a few 10's of nanometers
on a side - that's 1/1000 of the thickness
of a thin human hair.
This dimension is so small that MOSFETs can't
be viewed using an ordinary optical microscope,
whose resolution is limited by the wavelength
of visible light, which is 400 to 750nm.
For many years, engineers have been able to
shrink the device dimensions by a factor of
2 every 24 months or so,
an observation known as "Moore's Law" after
Gordon Moore, one of the founders of Intel,
who first remarked on this trend in 1965.
Each 50% shrink in dimensions enables integrated
circuit (IC) manufacturers to build four times
as many devices in the same area as before,
and, as we'll see, the devices themselves
get faster too!
An integrated circuit in 1975 might have had
2500 devices; today we're able to build ICs
with two to three billion devices.
Here's a quick tour of what we see in the
diagram.
The substrate upon which the IC is built is
a thin wafer of silicon crystal which has
had impurities added to make it conductive.
In this case the impurity was an acceptor
atom like Boron, and we characterize the doped
silicon as a p-type semiconductor.
The IC will include an electrical contact
to the p-type substrate, called the "bulk"
terminal, so we can control its voltage.
When want to provide electrical insulation
between conducting materials, we'll use a
layer of silicon dioxide (SiO2).
Normally the thickness of the insulator isn't
terribly important, except for when it's used
to isolate the gate of the transistor (shown
here in red) from the substrate.
The insulating layer in that region is very
thin so that the electrical field from charges
on the gate conductor can easily affect the
substrate.
The gate terminal of the transistor is a conductor,
in this case, polycrystalline silicon.
The gate, the thin oxide insulating layer,
and the p-type substrate form a capacitor,
where changing the voltage on the gate will
cause electrical changes in the p-type substrate
directly under the gate.
In early manufacturing processes the gate
terminal was made of metal, and the term "metal-oxide-semiconductor"
(MOS) is referring to this particular structure.
After the gate terminal is in place, donor
atoms such as Phosphorous are implanted into
the p-type substrate in two rectangular regions
on either side of the gate.
This changes those regions to an n-type semiconductor,
which become the final two terminals of the
MOSFET, called the source and the drain.
Note that source and drain are usually physically
identical and are distinguished by the role
they play during the operation of the device,
our next topic.
As we'll see in the next slide, the MOSFET
functions as a voltage-controlled switch connecting
the source and drain terminals of the device.
When the switch is conducting, current will
flow from the drain to the source through
the conducting channel formed as the second
plate of the gate capacitor.
The MOSFET has two critical dimensions: its
length L, which measures the distance the
current must cross as it flows from drain
to source, and its width W, which determines
how much channel is available to conduct current.
The the current, termed I_DS, flowing across
the switch is proportional to the ratio of
the channel's width to its length.
Typically, IC designers make the length as
short as possible.
When a news article refers to a "14nm process,"
the 14nm refers to the smallest allowable
value for the channel length.
And designers choose the channel width to
set the desired amount of current flow.
If I_DS is large, voltage transitions on the
source and drain nodes will be quick, at the
cost of a physically larger device.
To summarize: the MOSFET has four electrical
terminals: bulk, gate, source, and drain.
Two of the device dimensions are under the
control of the designer: the channel length,
usually chosen to be as small as possible,
and the channel width chosen to set the current
flow to the desired value.
It's a solid-state switch - there are no moving
parts - and the switch operation is controlled
by electrical fields determined by the relative
voltages of the four terminals.